jorge pablo valdez which from 77 to 80
he was the number one cocaine dealer in
the world okay
jorge luis jorge luis valdez jorge luis
valdez from cuba
that moves to miami
gets his degree then one of his clients
that's a market that they have every
month he's depositing 500 000 saying how
do you have this kind of money he says
listen we don't do this kind of stuff
this is just you know stuff that we have
to hide we have a cocaine business and
back then you know he was killing it he
made like 60 million dollars he's 21
years old cooking cowboys there's a
documentary about the guy so i said what
was it like being in cuba he says in
cuba he says you know you couldn't
believe in god
you could not believe in god why
couldn't you believe in god you know the
whole concept of communism you can't
believe in god state is god the state is
god the whole concept with hitler was
what you cannot believe in god it's it's
who it's i am your god right hitler is
your god
and dietrich bonhoeffer uh wrote about
this you know probably the story of
dietrich bonhoeffer it's a great story
kai that's another book you got to wrap
up with dietrich bonhoeffer so this guy
stood up to hitler and hitler couldn't
stand this guy and what he was doing
the moment you if you really want to
control the populace the first thing
that's got to go is believing in a
higher power
the moment you get rid of that
you don't believe you can go fight a
bigger opponent okay and this book naked
communist written by cleon skousen which
was a 15-year uh cia agent and he wrote
about a certain steps one of them was
indoctrination of the lgbtq
overly listen we all know somebody
that's gay in the family everybody has
somebody you're like yeah listen i've
known since you were i don't know
you've been like this for a long time so
it's not like it's you know it's like
hey what's up it's cool no problem right
everything's fine but the overly of
trying to get you to question those
thoughts of how do you know maybe what
if not what if this
you're starting to see some of those
things one of the things is faith get
people to stop believing in god because
once faith is gone people don't believe
they can fight against the system this
is the other one there's a lot of
different things that they're going
through as well everybody's equal
there's like 25 steps they're going
through gradually this is taking place
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]